vous restez avec nous en face aux
gothiques with
alors le bassiste chris blizzard un jeu
laurent pose des questions et la réponse
c'est le nom de quelqu'un voit là et je
suis les faut deviner qui sait vous
allez trouver très facilement
on va tout donner un exemple qu'on a
déjà évoqué tout à l'heure par exemple
je porte le nom d'un mime et c'est vrai
parfois que je ferais mieux de la fermer
oui marceau c'est ça c'est évident le
public peut jouer aussi si on trouvait
bien entendu alors les gagnants
gagneront le comme d'habitude le livre
de laurent qui est voilà hadopi pour eux
est quelqu'un que philippe bouvard
connaît bien justement j'ai fait un
huitième enfant à ma jeune épouse de
porte ce soit michel drucker qui meurent
en classe pour faire une neuvième si
vous êtes martin c'est la dame la banque
a gagné conseil au passage pendant que
je suis en prison pendant que je suis en
prison j'espère que ma femme ne s'en
tricote pas un autre nom connaît venait
barreau semaine deux semaines
tant pis pour toi j'en ai une poubelle
alors là tandis que je suis tout petit
tout rouge et je frappe à une vitre
bouvard dans un four micro ondes
si j'ai prévu la fin du monde pour le 11
août c'est parce qu'avec le génial pas
le temps de terminer c'est parce qu'avec
le pont du 15 août serait prêt à le
faire un week-end prolongé
c'est quand même pas mal ah tiens un peu
plus compliqué lors des derniers
championnats d'europe je n'ai pas obtenu
de médaille d'or parce que les seules
pièces jaunes que je récupère
maintenance avec bernadette chirac
doulieu douillet bravo bouvard
saskatoon d'actualité en ce moment aussi
hélas j'essaie de trouver que je suis
une personne sensible parce que si
j'avais été sensible j'aurais pas tirer
à l'arc goes my crozemarie
allez une dernière
je suis toujours habillée en noir parce
que ça me massive et g3 coussin sous les
fesses parce que ça me fait toujours
rêver beaucoup tarder son regard
derrière les regards d'égoûts à tout vol
mais regardez maintenant ce que vous
voulez mais là je me sens vraiment que
vous ne savez pas c'est que moi je suis
debout à l'ennemi